hey guys I'm just back with Tam and
we've got Jason here with us to talk
about buttholes buttholes
we're very much a hole actually okay
this is all we made a mistake that's
okay myself Hawk I'm so excited
I loved your first game how excited are
you to be bringing out another one I'm
very excited to bring out South Park the
fractured but whole for sure but I think
that everyone that was fast as a stick
of truth has a lot to look forward to
we've changed some things but we've kept
it that true South Park spirit right now
one of the things you've massively
changes the combat yes a little bit
about that yeah so we wanted to keep
turn-based combat because that worked
really well for jokes it really worked
well yeah people to be able to still
follow along with the story but we
wanted to still feel like you actually
were fighting in the environments that
you're exploring so that means that we
added grid-based sort of board game
style combat yeah okay so one of the
things I was interested me about this
game and the first game is like you're
kind of parroting two things at once
almost with this one so with the first
game it was kind of like not RPG kind of
parody this is a superhero obviously
you've got the little logo which is
evoking the Avengers style logo thing
and you're also kind of touching on a
soft walk is known for touching on
society as it is now and partying that
stuff so is that something that you're
doing again with this game or is it
you're trying to focus on the superhero
side and really make fun of that or are
you gonna be bringing in some of the
walls around us to poke fun of them you
know I think that it's always gonna get
pulled in like you I think all of the
superhero movie stuff that you see is
sort of pulling that in as well right
like whatever what are heroes fighting
against these days and that's these
these kids largely they're trying also
to you know be very serious super fun so
I think that the game tends to be
funniest for me when when they're being
serious and trying to take their game
very seriously they wanted they want to
build an amazing that's great franchise
which they to kids in South Park the
franchise is actually what being secure
is all about right not beating up bad
guys is just one aspect of it yeah yeah
so for people who might not know can you
set up the story for us around I mean
it's probably confusing
yes I'm talking about rock the fractured
but whole is this kid in a strip club
yeah so what does give us what happening
is a carbons idea is that if we could
save this missing cat in town if we
could find it yeah then we would won we
would be famous and we get a hundred
dollar reward one hundred dollars a lot
of money and that will kick off our
average highs and so that has led us to
sneak out of our houses at night and
here we're prepared up with Captain
diabetes yeah and he's Scott malkinson
diabetes boss and we're only cool enough
to be his sidekick tonight so we're kind
of following his orders or following his
lead and we're looking for a lady with
information about his isomcarol right
these gentlemen they're probably going
to be able to give us a name help us out
that's Scott just wants to ask some
questions they are insisting on first we
get dances and then we talk oh my god I
love it well okay it's probably a good
point I was gonna make firstly I've
probably noticed I'm Australian
I'm very sorry that we censored your
game good week on behalf of yeah yeah it
was horrible that happened although I
loved how you dealt with it oh wait the
sad koala um I have to ask you did you
reckon that's gonna happen this time
around
yeah I think so I mean this looks I mean
right now this is just good superheroing
yeah yeah on screen yeah baby she's got
some good dance moves but he's also
farting absolutely um in order to get
this guy to want to talk and yeah a nice
little quirk pagent became this is how I
conduct all my interviews well that's
good I mean if I smell that I get it we
want to like up the ante with that kind
of stuff or I mean it's just
quintessentially South Park right the
big thing is just to always make sure
that it has you know the the grow set of
stuff has to have a little bit of a
point to it yet well and and so if it's
just being shocking for shock value
alone it's not not really actually
necessarily and so we're always going to
be pushing the limits as much as we can
yeah and you know all that comes from
Matt and Trey so like
meaning my job isn't a sensor than my
job is to get their content into an
interactive problem so I said there was
nothing that you were like oh maybe we
can't do that it's all in there
I love it that's what I was hoping you
would say let's let's move on to
something a little more wholesome than
what's happening on screen so let's talk
about the specific RPG mechanics so what
kind of evolving the mechanics from the
previous games what other big things
that you introduced that kind of help
define the gameplay style and adapt it
to the superhero and then also the South
Park game so a couple things is that for
superheroes the way they look their
outfit their brand is a big part of it
so here you see the new katie's sort of
in this tank football sort of gear and
that actually doesn't change his stats
that's that's actually just part of your
superhero branding your identity um
separate from that you're leveling up by
kind of putting together this character
sheet because Cartman is really you know
he's your DM he wants he wants you guys
all beaten playing sort of a Dungeons &
Dragons superhero game for him you're
going through and you're collecting
these superhero classes that he's
divvying out to you and you can mix and
match those classes I would just sort of
in this case be sort of a cyborg
elementalist and then you're also
collecting
buddies to have on your team and here at
e3 we were showing just two-on-two keep
it easy for everybody else that's what's
going on but the the combats evolved to
have four people on your side against
waves of enemies and it could be a lot
different come on I'd love to know it
can you still wander around town in this
game course last game I bloody love that
that was amazing
can we expect collectables all kinds of
things to do around town what's the
questing system like well we your South
Park is gonna feel familiar can I only
been a couple days later so like oh yeah
rather than neighborhood still feels
like home but we've added some to
businesses like hip
here yeah and next door to that is the
buca di faggocini which is the local
Italian restaurant that's all up and
should keep our town from the recent
episode yeah
and so there's new places to explore but
it should still feel pretty familiar and
then in terms of questing you know it's
all kind of been driven bought by your
phone like an eel she kind of threw the
demo that the players got a crafting app
and all these different they're using
it's all just built into their phone
yeah and yeah we will take you around
this this things to collect like like
Craig and tweek Yowie and stuff like
that all right yeah the last game I
think I mean I don't want to say this
low expectations for when you know their
TV show is brought to a video game but I
thought you did it exceptionally well
and uh there was a it was a very big
game as well it's bigger than I expected
Oh should we expect that kind of scale
again yeah absolutely yeah say the
biggest story that I think Matt trave
ever tried to tell and like the South
Park studios group is working hard on
this game as we speak
yeah and so like I think it's the
biggest story they've ever heard in one
go as well and yeah it's definitely a
lot of content um and I I think
everybody's going to be happy with the
story that they've come up with it's
like the stick of truth story like it
goes places you might not expect can you
speak a little bit about the kind of
shift in development duties that
happened from the first game to the
second game obviously obsidian developed
the first one and now it's being
developed in-house by Ubisoft how did
that kind of come about and what was
like matte and Trey's reaction to it
there are a couple of people that have
had they've been very vocal about having
a rough time in games and they kind of
reached a point where they felt safe
with obsidian and they felt like they
made that connection how did that kind
of the shift entirely tubes off go down
and was a discussion like and was there
any point where I was like this might be
a bit of an issue like there might be I
think that I mean for them they knew
that their studio and learn to make good
games they they knew that they'd had a
practice that they felt that they'd
gotten into a stick and they wanted to
continue that forward and with Ubisoft
it was like our biggest thing was trying
to make sure that we created a process
and a pipeline that was going to
try to embrace the strengths and
everything that they had learned about
the last game and that meant giving them
the iteration time that they were kind
of used to so that that's why we went
with the snowdrop engine which means
bringing it internal and like snowdrop
just basically can consume assets from
the show we just tried to build
basically a show pipeline for the Rhine
we can just make make the jokes that
they're after okay so you're actually
using stuff from the main show in the
game okay does that make it easier to
kind of stay current with with the
actual what's the jokes and the new kind
of new characters that might be
appearing in the show yeah I mean that's
how we can just throw shitty pot down
and yeah develop that is that why I mean
this is a strange question now I don't
know if you can speak to it but like
obviously the games been delayed a few
times is that perhaps because you're
trying to keep up to date and is there a
point where you like what what spirit
what's the reason behind it laser you've
been having recently I mean weird we're
not just we're still just trying to tell
this story I think that for the delays
it was really about trying to make sure
that we had everybody's expectations
yeah we had high expectations of the
game South Park of course has high
expectations in a game and I think the
players deserve to have a great game and
so when it came down to it we had to
decide this what we all wanted is this
what people expect and it wasn't there
yet and so so one of the things that I
was thinking about as as a fan of the
series and the games is like the delays
are happening at some time when things
are happening in the world that are very
South Park Perry edible and rifle making
jokes about in the way that Matt and
Trey would do can we expect some
commentary on what's happening around us
in the world right now I think that
we're gonna tell this is the best
superhero story that we can and I think
that they'll kind of find where to put
those things in whether it's in the show
or our game okay cool do you see more
South Park games down line I really
really hope so yeah I love them good
so much fun to work on that we love them
turn good sweet um
that's fantastic is what's your favorite
thing that you've included in the sequel
um I love all of the kids that we got to
get involved like instead of just
necessarily the main kids guys like
Scott malkinson captain diabetes not a
character people necessarily like our
super familiar with ya little Scott
t-shirt but you know like to have those
characters and those friends from the
show getting included in getting some
screen time and getting to see hear
those different voices coming to it has
been a treat I'm a big fan of Timmy as
child's exhibit on a high end giving me
a job with that
props well played Thank You thing I
think there's a very significant
likeliness that this is going to be just
as funny if not more funny than the last
one so thank you so much for making it
basically we're really excited to play
it I'm personally just glad that we're
getting the best game possible yes um
out of all this and thank you so much
for talking to us I think you fantastic
you can pick up the game on October 17
as we've said this year so not too long
to wait
thanks very much we'll see you again
soon